PROFESSOR: We can go
a step forward now.
So we're trying to
understand these operators.
And the next claim is
that if you multiply
an arbitrary upward
permutation operator times S,
or you multiply on the
other side, it's the same.
And in fact, it's just S. On
the other hand, if you multiply
by a permutation operator
A, it is still the same
as multiplying A from the right
with that permutation operator.
But this time you get
epsilon alpha 0 times A.
So this is a claim
of the simple way
in which permutation
operators interact with your A
and S. So here is, again,
the same kind of argument.
We'll say it first.
So P alpha 0 acting on the
list of permutation operators
just rearranges the list.
We just argue that taking the
inverse of the permutation
operators just
rearranges the list.
Multiplying by P
alpha 0 the list
of all permutation operators--
here you have all the
permutation operators.
Now you multiply by P alpha 0.
And then the claim is that
they just go somewhere
but you get the same
list at the end.
Now that, again, you can
prove by the same argument.
Show that two elements
that are different
here go to two elements
that are different.
And any element
here can be written
as P alpha 0 of something here.
I think you can do that.
And it's a repeat of this kind
of argument we've been doing.
So P alpha 0
rearranges the list.
So that's a first thing.
So therefore, let's
try one of these.
So the first one, P alpha
0 on S. So all we can do
is use the formula
for S. So you have 1
over N factorial, the sum of.
S is the sum over
alpha of P alpha.
But now we have P alpha 0.
And then we don't really
do much at this stage.
We say, look, by this claim
that P alpha 0 rearranges
all the operators, this is
just another sum, P beta,
of all the operators.
This P alpha 0 times P
alpha is another operator.
But at the end of the job,
when you sum over alpha,
you get just the
list rearranged.
So here it is, the
list, rearranged.
So this is back to S.
For the A case--
let's do it.
P alpha 0.
We have to work a little more.
A is always a
little more subtle.
1 over N factorial
alpha P alpha 0.
But this time I have the epsilon
alpha of the A. P alpha 0 P
alpha.
OK.
To make this clear, I'm going to
put the sine factor two times.
So we'll have sum over alpha.
I'll put epsilon alpha.
And then I'll put
epsilon alpha 0.
Then another epsilon alpha 0.
Whatever epsilon alpha 0 is
I can do this because I'm
inserting just the 1 here.
And then we have
P alpha 0 P alpha.
Now look at this operator
and look at this sine factor.
A few things are clear here.
This epsilon alpha 0 has
nothing to do with the sum.
So this epsilon alpha 0
can go out of the sum.
And then you have a sum--
so 1 over N factorial
epsilon alpha 0.
The sum of this
epsilon alpha epsilon
alpha 0 P alpha 0 P alpha.
But here, it's clear that
if this is some P beta,
this sine factor is,
in fact, epsilon beta,
because if P beta
is made by these two
permutations of the sine
factor of that permutation,
it's the product of
these two sine factors.
This is kind of clear
because it's just
a number of
transpositions again.
This is counting the number
of transpositions mode two.
And this works like that.
If you have two
even permutations,
the product is an
even permutation.
And therefore, the two
pluses give you a plus.
If one is even and one
is odd, the product
is an odd permutation, and
you have a 1 and a minus 1.
This product is minus 1.
So this is an epsilon
beta P beta sum over beta.
And that is the antisymmetrizer.
So you've got epsilon
alpha 0 in here,
and the rest is, again,
the antisymmetrizer.
So these two properties
have been proven.
I've proven them when
P is from the left.
The proof when P is from
the right is very similar.
Almost no changes.
OK.
Little by little,
these operators
are a little complicated
because they have lots of terms.
And therefore, manipulating
them requires some care.
But now we're ready for the main
claim about these operators.
We can do the
arithmetic with them,
and finally say that A and
S are orthogonal projectors.
So what does that mean?
It means that S squared is equal
to S, A squared is equal to A,
and we'll also show that
they're orthogonal to each other
in that AS equal SA
equals 0 as well.
So if you first apply the
symmetrization operator
to a state and then you
apply the antisymmetrization,
you get 0.
So once you symmetrize,
that symmetric state
has no component along
the antisymmetric state.
They're complementary.
So this is really what you
want from these operators.
They're doing the right job.
So this is the last thing
we need to prove about them.
But by now, we really
have worked quite well.
So it's going to be simple.
The other statement, of course,
of orthogonal projectors
also includes the fact that
they are Hermitian operators.
So we already showed
that they are Hermitian,
so we're almost there.
We just need to prove that
these two things happen.
So let's see how
difficult or easy this is.
So first case, the S squared
equal S. S squared is
S times S, so I will write
it as one S, here, acting
on the other S.
Now, the next step
is just erasing this
parenthesis over alpha.
And now we have it there.
The product of any
projector times S is S.
So projector in alpha
is just S. So we'll
have 1 over N factorial,
the sum over alpha of S.
But S has no alpha index.
So it goes out of the sum.
It's equal to S times 1 over N
factorial, the sum over alpha
of 1.
And the sum over alpha
of 1 is a 1 added
for each element of the
permutation group, which
is N factorial elements.
Therefore, this
sum is N factorial.
And therefore, this cancels
with that N factorial
and we get S, as we wanted.
So S squared is S. It
is a projector operator.
That's good.
Let's do the second.
A squared is going to be 1 over
N factorial sum epsilon alpha P
alpha acting on an antisymmetric
A. So this is the first A,
and there's the second A. I
should put the sum over alpha.
But we already
calculated P alpha on A.
This is sum over
alpha epsilon alpha.
And P alpha on A was
calculated on that board.
It's just another
epsilon alpha times A.
Well, epsilon alpha
times epsilon alpha,
whether is 1 or minus 1,
the product is just plus 1.
So you get 1 over N factorial.
And again, the sum over
alpha of A, the A goes out.
Sum over alpha of 1,
and we're back to A.
So A squared is also A.
Finally, let's do one of
those mixed products, three.
A multiplied with
S. So as usual,
we write the first
operator explicitly.
Epsilon alpha P alpha on S. But
P alpha on S, we know already,
is just S. So 1
over N factorial sum
over alpha epsilon
alpha times S.
The S goes out.
1 over N factorial S sum
over alpha of epsilon alpha.
That's as far as we
can simplify this.
And then we recall, in
any permutation group Sn,
the number of even
permutations is
equal to the number
of odd permutations.
So there is equal
number of pluses
and equal number of
minuses in that sum.
So this sum is equal to 0.
And therefore, this result is 0.
The operators are orthogonal,
and they will do the job.
So good.
We have orthogonal operators.
And therefore, we can do with
these projectors what you would
expect we should be able to do.
So here it is, the
last statement.
S takes V tensor
N to Sym N of V.
It's a projector to
the symmetric states.
Why is that?
Well, take a psi belonging
to V tensor N. Then
consider S on psi.
That's the operator, S,
acting on the state, psi.
And that should be
a symmetric state.
And to check that it's symmetric
we apply a P alpha on S psi.
But P alpha on S is S,
so that's just S psi.
So the state of psi
is independent--
unchanged-- by the
action of the P alpha.
So the state S psi is, indeed--
this implies that S psi
belongs to Sym N V, as claimed.
So the operator does
what you wanted it to do.
This property helps
for the other one.
So A is an operator that takes
arbitrary states in the tensor
product to anti N V.
So indeed, if, again,
you have some psi in V N,
you can then form A psi
and see where it lies.
For that you apply
P alpha on A psi.
But P alpha on A from
that middle blackboard
is epsilon alpha A psi.
But that is precisely
the definition
of an antisymmetric state.
So indeed, A takes states
to antisymmetric states.
If you think of the vector
space V tensor N here,
there's some subspace here, Sym
N V, and some subspace here,
anti N V. And
these two subspaces
don't contain any
common element.
Maybe I should--
well, I don't know.
Maybe I should really make
them touch at one point.
That point would be what vector?
AUDIENCE: 0?
PROFESSOR: 0.
Yes.
If you have a vector subspace
it has to have the 0 vector.
So here is the 0 vector.
But they don't fill
the whole thing.
In general, they don't
fill the whole thing.
When you have two particle
states, however, they do.
Remember when we
had N equals 2, we
had the symmetrizer
was 1 plus P 2 1.
And A was 1/2 1 minus P 2 1.
In that case, the symmetrizer
plus the antisymmetrizer
was equal to 1.
But this is only
for two particles.
If you have three particles,
this will not work.
Suppose I get three particles--
maybe I'll use this blackboard.
And the fact that S plus A
is equal to the unit operator
means something, of course.
It means that still
for N equals 2,
means that any
vector can be written
as S plus A times the
vector, because this is 1.
And therefore, it's SV plus AV.
So any vector where V belongs to
the tensor product, because you
have two particles, can be
written as a symmetric state
plus an antisymmetric state.
That is the statement
that the symmetric states
plus the antisymmetric
state span the space.
So that is true
for N equals to 2.
So in N equals to 2, the
two states, the two spaces,
span the space.
On the other hand, for N
equals to 3, remember we had--
and this is a good way to
write some things explicitly.
If you have N equals to 3,
you have the permutation 1 2
3, which is the identity,
the permutation 3 1 2,
the permutation of 2 3 1.
All these were
even permutations.
This is original, and this can
be built with two permutations.
Then you have P 1 3 2,
where you flip just 2 and 3.
This has one transposition.
You can cycle them.
3 2 1.
P 2 1 3.
These are the even, and here
are the odd permutations.
So this was for three particles.
Six operators, three
even, three odd.
So what is the symmetrizer?
The symmetrizer, 1
over 3 factorial.
And you should sum.
So it's 1 over 3
factorial, which is 6.
The 1 plus P 3 1 2 plus P 2 3 1.
I keep adding.
You should add all of them.
Plus P 3 2 1 plus P 2 1 3.
Boom.
That's it.
All the ones, you
have to add them.
What is A is 1/6.
You add the ones that are even.
1 plus P 3 1 2 plus P
2 1 3, and you subtract
all the ones that are odd.
So you minus P 1 3 2 minus
P 3 2 1 minus P 2 1 3.
So those are the two operators
in case you wanted to see them.
But now notice that A plus S
is equal to 1/3 1 plus P 3 1 2
plus P 2 3 1.
And that's not the equal to
the identity, as it was before.
It's equal to something else.
So you cannot say that the
vector is equal to A plus S
times the vector.
That's not true here.
Doesn't happen.
So there is more to
the triple tensor
product than the
symmetric states
and the antisymmetric states.
That's a nice subject for a
slightly more advanced course
in quantum mechanics where you
studying the Young tableaux
of the permutation group.
And while for two things, two
objects that are represented
with Young tableaux
with little squares,
you can form something
that is called
symmetric and antisymmetric,
for three objects you
can form a symmetric
object, you can
form an antisymmetric
object, but you can
form a mixed symmetry object.
And this Young
tableaux represent
the tensors that enter here.
There are other projectors
to this kind of object.
These objects are not
symmetric nor antisymmetric.
They have partial symmetry
and partial antisymmetry.
And they take a while to get
around to visualize them.
But that's why the permutation
group is interesting
and why we try to understand
it better and better.
So that's basically
the mathematics
that we need for
understanding permutations.
So we're going to do
some of the physics that
follows from this now.